[Applause]
welcome to a special edition of down the
middle
i'm so pleased that at the last moment
here
uh
given everything that's going on in the
world that dr jonathan ward was able to
join me uh the author of china's vision
of victory and founder of atlas
organization is a preeminent expert
on all things china russian indian you
kind of see where i'm going with this he
speaks five languages fluently including
chinese and russian and we are so
fortunate to have him with us today to
help us
have a better understanding of what it
is that's taking place historically
before our very eyes in real time now
that social media is part of one of the
largest skirmishes that we've seen in
our lifetimes certainly jonathan thank
you for being with me today i really
appreciate you doing this last minute
thank you danielle great to be here
so um let's let's start as i always do
let's get a little bit of background
we're both graduates of columbia
university but i
i certainly was not 19 years old with
visions of getting a degree in chinese
and russian
so give us a little bit of your
background
what brought you to that place
um
where where was your interest born in
such far-flung
countries with cultures and societies
and economies that are so very foreign
to what we think of here in the united
states absolutely danielle so as a
teenager i really had this basic
intuition that i wanted to learn the
word world's most widely spoken
languages and i thought that i wanted to
go out and find out what was going on in
my lifetime and the best way to do that
would be to understand um you know the
languages that would give me access to
what the world was going to be in my
time so that was russian chinese arabic
spanish french those were the ones that
i started on i mean later in my travels
you know pick up indonesia and lao and
things like that but you know bottom
line colombia allowed me to to begin
that journey of languages countries
cultures as a 19 year old i lived in
russia and i lived in india
began my study of all these places and
then ultimately wound up spending five
years living all over the earth
in russia china india latin america and
middle east you name it and going around
at sort of a village level in many
countries where i just stay in people's
homes and learn from them and basically
ask them questions about how they saw
their you know their country their
future their past and what did this all
add up to um and eventually that led to
oxford where i wound up with a doctorate
in china india relations initially was
going to do russia china and was taught
by you know the greatest historians in
the world to go and um
learn these countries that i'd spent
time on in far greater depth and the
rest sort of went from there so it's
been a journey that i've been on
for almost 20 years now having begun as
a teenager
so let's let's talk a little bit about
the the background of your learning why
the pivot
why was learning about india more
important
at the time
well um by the time i was at oxford i
think i had a basic sense that um
you know
russia and china was was going to be a
very dark subject to study in that kind
of depth for so many years and you know
i did wind up studying a great deal um
of russian history and chinese as well
as as i moved into
the indian side but there just seemed to
be sort of a um you know to mitigate
this a bit by studying a country that
would ultimately be aligned to the
united states and a friend of the
world's democracies rather than going
fully down this path of moscow and
beijing and in that kind of doctrinal
level depth
you know i did a great amount of that
but um it was good to put another
country into this that balanced that
picture out and gave me insight into you
know what's ultimately becoming the 21st
century free world and not just our
adversaries alone
so um
what were your
what were your biggest takeaways in
terms of
alliances forged
the
basis what got us here historically
to where
as we've seen in a matter of weeks
we've kind of seen where the lines are
drawn whereas
the last 20 years of
your career
we've only been able to hypothesize to
wonder what would happen in a moment of
aggression because nothing like this of
this magnitude
has ever happened that has
that's prompted the world to ask the
question of individual countries
whose side are you on
what got us here
right and this is a very important
question because when we look at the
ukraine crisis right now i think what
we're beginning to understand um you
know not those of us that have been
paying attention to this in great depth
but you know the world as a whole is
beginning to understand that we i think
are in a state of conflict between
aggressive authoritarian states namely
russia and china and ultimately the free
world is is going to be
it's going to have to come back and and
protect itself and integrate you know
the democracies are going to have to
work together to solve a fundamental
problem which we never actually solved
which was after the cold war we
basically did not have a concept of
where russia might wind up and what's
perhaps even more dangerous and this
were yet to see
you know we enabled and and empowered
and funded and provided technology and
integration into the world economy for
an unreconstructed authoritarian state
which um
you know just prior to gaining most
favored nation status had you know
murdered many um young people in
tiananmen square and was in the process
of building an apparatus of repression
that that um you know is we just never
decided to hold that to account and
instead we um basically opened the doors
uh to the world so we have a so you're
speaking to the world trade organization
entries online right but also uh
permanent trading relations i mean just
the the sort of um you know i think the
beginning of private sector engagement
with china is really before that
constant validation has it not right so
so you know
you know you have the opening to china
taking place not just politically and in
the cold war context but in a post-cold
war economic and business context that
frankly was was very foolish um and and
many politicians did talk about how the
idea was that if china got rich it would
liberalize and none of that has happened
and what nobody cared about what nobody
had enough knowledge about or or um you
know the will to go and understand this
was that um
the communist party had a very clear
idea of its own as to where it would
wind up
on the world stage i.e as a dominant the
dominant player in the world system and
those are the kinds of things that i
became very acquainted with um you know
travel's led to some insight into that
certainly studying at oxford did you
know an advisor to the pentagon that all
helped but ultimately in china's vision
of victory my book putting all of those
documents together to understand how the
party's vision really works we're
dealing with russia and china together
and and i think that bigger issue is
manifesting now in ukraine um but we
have a far greater um challenge on our
hands i i'm curious
are we witnessing an alliance between
russia and china because there's there
is a great debate right now
as to
uh as to their relationship with one
another and of course so much of this
can be
crafted by the media what our
perceptions are
well i think it's a very deep
relationship and people should um
understand that the russia china
relationship has been built you know
between putin and xi jinping and you
know jintao even over the last decade i
mean the military exercises the economic
relationship you know the diplomatic
sort of coordination is is really many
years in the making at this point i mean
they've and and i think if we go back to
the moment in 2014 where russia seized
crimea and china began you know to they
sent the oil rig out to the south china
sea and then the island building started
and this stuff is essentially i think
loosely but truly coordinated and then
just in you know just a month ago or so
at the olympics when putin goes and
essentially gets this joint statement
and they release this joint statement it
shows and there are many other signs of
this and sort of documents that reveal
this but you know the latest one that i
think people are paying attention to is
actually a very profound strategic
document i mean it explains that they
are willing essentially to to take the
burden to share the burden of pushing
against the united states pushing
against the world's democracies i mean
they talk about they are jointly aligned
on opposing nato expansion and they're
jointly aligned on you know opposing the
u.s free and open indo-pacific
strategies you know shared by japan and
others so this is very much i think a
more strategic um
relationship than than many people know
and i say it is also somebody who my
initial work at oxford was on the um
sino-soviet split in the role of
nationalism russian and chinese
nationalism and you know how did that
relationship come together and then fall
apart um but i think if you if there is
that that famous um maybe you can
recount when khrushchev came to
china
and was made to swim
right
but in any case um you know nikita
khrushchev and and now in many ways had
stalin as his mentor but he never
respected nikita kirchoff and the
episode you're referring to when when um
you know khrushchev winds up at jonghyun
high to meet with mao zedong and now is
of course a famous swimmer having you
know swim across various rivers in china
for popular effect and then here's
khrushchev who doesn't know how to do
that and there's little has to wear
little floaties there and of course it's
very embarrassing and now was always in
the process then of being unwilling to
accept a role as junior partner but he
ultimately took his country to war with
you know not only in the korean war
against the united states and the united
nations forces but you know fought
border wars against india against the
soviet union
so this is uh that was a dictator who
chose to fight america you know uh india
in the ussr and to do away and
essentially to destroy all of um china's
intern you know significant
international relationships for the sake
of um you know being unwilling to be the
the junior partner partners everybody
so and it would appear that they've
succeeded
well that that i guess is uh well i'm
i'm not saying fit a complete but i'm
saying that they certainly they're
certainly not junior to russia
yes and that's of course the the the
sort of um important piece of of the
current situation is to have
not china but um the russia as the the
junior subservient partner here and many
of the things that i think are parallel
in the 21st century i mean for instance
it was you know the soviet union sending
advisers into china to help them you
know figure out how to be at that point
an industrial economy and now it's
huawei going into russia to help them
secure their systems it's chinese banks
that might be purchasing equity stakes
in russian
oil companies so the relationship is
monumentally in the reverse um and yet
russia is still a very
significant military challenger to the
u.s to europe i mean it's it's the
dominant variable in european security
is is you know the dangers posed by
by uh russia as a as a you know with its
strategic nuclear forces and all the
rest of it so for china to wind up in
this position where they essentially
have have russia as an economic
dependency that yet has a
you know all things considered a very
powerful military um that's that's you
know uh quite an alarming situation for
the united states and the rest of the
world to have this partnership coming
together in a way that is truly
dangerous
what what went wrong uh after the wall
came down what was
you've done a great job of explaining
what the cost has been to date of not
being more preemptive about china's
vision
of victory as a world as a world
community
and we let them proceed
in gaining power in being industrialized
in accessing world trade in in in having
their economy grow to the extent that it
has such their contender to be the
largest in the world what did we do
wrong with russia
well with russia i think i think there
was you know george f kennan pointed
this out sort of at the very end of his
life in the 90s saying that you know if
we don't have a sense of where this is
going we're going to wind up with the
second cold war in russia he was
referring to you know the lack of sort
of a military and security concept for
europe so i think we we never really
solved uh or had a vision for security
in europe and how to how to resolve that
i think there was
you know there were some attempts to to
probably do that i mean you had you know
russian um you know
sort of observers to nato for for many
many decades and that sort of thing but
you know fundamentally i think between
the united states and europe we probably
didn't figure out um what to do but then
the the positive thing i think is the
proliferation of democracy and the fact
that you have these you know countries
that as we see with ukrainians are very
firmly fighting for for their freedom
and sovereignty and that's a genuine and
real thing and i i don't think that um
you know the fact that you could have
what what um someone once said to me in
london the greatest expansion of human
freedom at any time you know
in memory uh taking place after the fall
of the wall and that being
in eastern europe um
i think that's something that our values
would always have to support that so so
we are um you know i think we're right
to to think that um you know we can't
blame this on ourselves when it comes to
russia and you you have them reacting to
um you know free societies um in in
europe that do very much want to be part
of the free world so um
explain it you know we hear these
stories of you know a sniper from canada
going over to to ukraine and
and doing what he can to take out
general's plural in the russian army uh
there is a worldwide outpouring of
support
for ukraine that is it's so fortifying
it's so
it's just it's it bolsters the soul to
watch to witness this
why
why has nato becomes such a hindrance
to
actually helping
ukraine
i think the issue here for um you know
those
in in charge of let's say the us
government and others is is you know
looking at this from the perspective of
um wanting to avoid um you know a war
with russia direct you know no flies on
that sort of team you're talking about
engaging directly against the russian
military which i think is a different
thing
than um what this moment speaks to for
the human being i mean there's no
question that this is
um you know
the most significant expression of the
fight for human freedom i think against
a very very malignant dangerous forces
in you know that we've seen and and i
think hong kong was also also that
expression it received far less
attention um
but you know we're in a period where in
xinjiang you have um you know genocide
and human rights atrocities taking place
in hong kong you had the destruction of
one of the finest cities of the in the
world by the communist party of china
and and now in ukraine i mean we are
very much i think in my mind um fighting
against um you know
horrific totalitarian dictatorships and
one of which acts more subtly you know
china and the other is is acting with
you know quite brutal effect in front of
our eyes um so the free world as i see
it in the united states as i see it and
despite my um you know time as a sort of
traveler and linguist and doing all of
that in scholar i mean you know at an
early age i also had
so many ideas of america's role in the
world too and i think that's the part
that we have to
uh reimagine in the 21st century we did
not you know you ask what went wrong
after the the fall of the wall i think
america lacked its own vision of what to
do after the cold war and we're going to
need that we're going to need our own
vision of victory our own sense of how
to read rebuild the world so that it's
secure for our values for our prosperity
for those of our allies and friends all
across the planet we know exactly who
our allies and friends are i mean that's
something that is the i think the
abundant riches of the post-cold war
world is the u.s alliance system from
europe to asia and many places in
between we have um
you know quite a good structure to work
with but we're going to need a sense of
how to ultimately overcome these two
challenges russia and china both of whom
have a sense of history and it's
expressed in their own documents and
speeches and that's what i have worked
with for for a long time but i mean the
the letter that putin required all
russian troops to read
was
it
it was it was huge it was comprehensive
it was it went all the way back to
to the very beginnings and this was
something that that was very interesting
for me danielle there was a point in my
convergence of a linguist and a traveler
and scholar and probably even before i
went to graduate school but where i
realized that a history of the world
written in russian or in chinese or in
arabic or in any you could take
something history of the world in any of
those languages would have been
fundamentally different than the ones
that we read and i realized you know
through that that you know we don't all
have the same view of where everything
is and we're going to be dealing with
those different world views um asserting
themselves in terms of power you know
economic military diplomatic you know
that contest for where the world goes is
fundamentally
a clash of views of history and with the
chinese side i've been you know working
on that for a long time and with the
russian side you you look at putin's
speeches and these are um
documents that have an unlimited scope
for for essentially fighting the west i
mean it's very clear and that's what's
aligning right now is the the vision
that the communist party of china has
the great rejuvenation of the chinese
nation the century of humiliation the
idea that by 2049 they become the
dominant player
and then this putinis view that frankly
was not something i experienced among
ordinary russians in my travels there um
but this putin is feeling they were
going but yes right and that that you
know
that they basically have to go and
redress essentially what they see is the
um you know the humiliation of russia
and you know after the cold war even so
so and then that there are these
territories that they think belong to
them so you have two dictatorships that
have
very similar things in common and people
like to say that you know ideology is
not a part of this contest it's not
socialism versus you know capitalism
democracy but what it is is you know
ideas are very much a part of it the
idea that you know one country has has
been humiliated and will restore itself
and the other has these territories that
belong to it and they were been
humiliated by the west
that's what we're doing these parallels
are
undeniable or irrefutable
but how um
you were getting to the next
to my next question and that would be
how does the average russian perceive
what's happening
is it just a matter of you wake up the
next day and starbucks is gone you wake
up the next day mcdonald's
your your media is controlled your
ability to communicate outside the
countries
but surely
they know something is happening
oh no doubt no doubt and then you know
i'm no longer in touch with that aspect
of things unfortunately but i do think
that is one of the most important things
that you know that we can know as a
country that the united states has to
you know um
be very cognizant of is is how do you
know ordinary people in some of our
adversary states actually you know
interact with
the um desires and strategies that their
rulers are imposing um but in any case i
mean i think that the economic um you
know
aspect which i think is incredibly
important here i mean the sanctions and
sort of state killer level sanctions
that we've unleashed on russia i mean
this is a very powerful piece of the
western
tool kit and for for the past couple
years since my book came out i've been
talking a lot about the need for
economic containment
when it comes to china or just the
history of sort of western economic
warfare i mean we have a very very
potent toolkit that we're now watching
you know utilized against a
a foreign aggressor in an adversary
totalitarian you know state and and that
toolkit i think is going to be among the
most important things we have in our
contest with both russia and china so if
i hear you correctly we're we're more
strategically deploying sanctions
well i think i think that you know the
the fundamental pieces right now of how
the united states and you know allies
are interacting with with the crimea
crisis excuse me with the ukraine crisis
of course are um you know
very impressive sanctions um you know
the flight of businesses from russia is
also incredibly important and those that
are deeply embedded in china across the
fortune 500 right now should be taking
note of what it looks like to have to
change overnight you may not want to do
that and the china exposure is so much
greater than the russian exposure well
that's the so i mean this is a microcosm
of this is the world's 11th largest
economy compared to the world's second
right largest right exactly and and when
it comes time to go it's it comes time
to go
so um and then the fact that there is a
genuinely um
you know there there's a battlefield
situation in which the ukrainians have
been um amazing defenders of their
country and and the weaponry that
they're utilizing i mean the javelins
the stingers and laws i mean that's all
appears to be very successful in the
field and the fact that this wasn't
um you know an easy victory for putin by
any stretch thus far and hopefully it
will not you know wind up there but the
ukrainian will to fight has been
extraordinary so those two variables
economic um
you know sort of big macro sanctions not
small sort of uh you know export
controls or this and that but things
that actually you know bring
bring some some real effect to the
russian economy plus the fact that this
is not yet a fight that they have won
those are um very key pieces here so um
i'm i'm curious i'm going to pivot for
just a minute because when the time came
at the united nations security council
uh india did not vote with the united
states
right
what what's i mean
talk to me about fertilizer and how
important
having an appreciation
of how undeveloped india's economy is
and how that might have played into this
decision
well i mean the way that i would look at
india's position in this crisis um is is
is not
really um it's not really about
economics in this case i think what it
is is you know as as many people know i
mean india's history of non-alignment
since independence 1947 and they
basically you know did not want to
choose sides in the cold war between the
soviet union and the united states they
wanted to create a third way they did
this with china they basically brought
china in and said you know together
we're going to go and present an
alternative to the world's decolonizing
nations and they had a conference in
1954
where um you know nations from across
asia and africa and you know were
invited to come and find this third way
together where we did not you know she
wouldn't be um part of the the cold war
between the west and the soviet bloc
and that's always been a core piece of
indian principles the idea that we're
not going to you know
engage on one side or the other we have
our own independent path and then i
think also in terms of practice it also
meant essentially that they wanted to
have relations with both the ussr and
the united states i mean both america
and
the russians were competing for
influence in india very substantially in
the 1950s and 60s and such um so you
know that history of non-alignment cure
which translates also into maintaining
relations with russian america i mean i
think that's going to have to come to a
head at a certain point you know india
and my mind will have to make choices
about where it sits in the world the
idea that you can
remain so open to moscow
in order to balance against china and to
think that that doesn't cost you with
the united states or the broader
democrat democratic world
i think is not the right strategy for
the 21st century i mean india i think is
vital to the success of the world's
democracies in our contests with china
and with russia um but a lot of what
they care about is um you know during
the sign of soviet split they understood
better than we did because they had such
close relations with the soviet union
that that relationship was coming apart
the soviet you know sino-soviet split
was taking place in the meantime there's
the russia china executing the
china-india border war in 1962. so they
were very afraid of having china backed
by russia putting that relationship back
together
if they swung too close to the west so
you know today i mean they're they're
you know a lot of their military and
their parts for their military come from
from russia and they they want to sort
of have
you know both sides of this but i think
there's a much more important um you
know principled stance and practical
requirement that india comes to the
democratic world and sees what the
russia china
you know ambitions really are and that
they
do decide to fully join the fruit
uh we've we've seen some hesitation on
the parts of some european
allies namely germany
right and germany's been a a complicated
issue and a sticking point for for many
thinking about you know
american security and all the rest of it
and you know you can sort of glibly sum
up that german foreign policy was to
sell cars to china to buy gas from
russia and hope that nato will protect
them and of course that's not a foreign
policy that's going to help
you know the democracies in the long run
and they're going to have to revise
their china policy and they're going to
have to absolutely revise the russia
policies they're doing but the steps
that we appear to be seeing with germany
now committing to um defense expenditure
and really doing the things that they
that we need them to do in europe um
that's all been brought about by this
crisis i think there's been a real
awakening there that's important and
that awakening in my mind should go
beyond the um the immediate um
problem of of russian aggression and to
the broader question of the russia-china
um you know joint partnership that is is
creating these these issues
so um
the average ukrainian
is it a country that we would consider
to be
united
in terms of idealism
because you're talking about
chinese thinking and russian thinking or
at least they're leaders what i
shouldn't be speaking for the people of
either country but their leaders
thinking is aligned
and they've been maligned historically
and so they're they're in it to get back
what is theirs and i understand that but
do the are the people of ukraine
fully behind zilinski
well and and to your point i think it's
important to to to make that clear that
you're talking about you know
ideas and essentially pathologies that
exist at a leadership level in russia
and china this stuff has been curated
and promoted among the population to
varying degrees of effect but it's very
much which you can do in a controlled
environment controlled media but right
that's not the case
with ukraine well ukrainians ukraine is
a democracy of course and a totally i
mean utterly you know it's the democracy
is dealing with these authoritarian
ideologies that's and that's the in many
ways the essence of our our problem and
the problem that we'll be dealing with
for the next you know 10 or 20 years or
however long it takes for us to find
a way to to solve this but um you know
in ukraine i mean i think it's you know
the the response from the entire world
has been so extraordinary and i think um
you know as in hong kong and other
places i mean you know anyone in the
free world
you know always a debt of gratitude to
those that are actually fighting for it
and um you know it's very it's very uh i
mean i think we all feel that way um and
and you know beyond that i obviously
cannot speak for
the people of any country
no i mean i'm
your emotion right now i think is so
shared
and it's so important to understand uh
you know
where we are
talk a little bit about
timing
because it was pretty obvious that
russia waited until after the olympics
was over
to cross the border two days after the
olympics ended they invaded
ukraine
so we know what his time line looked
like
where's xi jinping's mind in terms of
timing his next potential move or not
or not and and right and and i think
that another important piece of of
putin's timing here was
in my mind you know getting that
assurance from beijing having that it's
very public it's very obvious it's right
in our faces right there you can read
this document see what it says he you
know it was uh issued in the context of
massive troop buildups that are
pre-positioned for an invasion so it was
you know if anyone's saying that that
was a surprise to china that i don't
think is is there military exercises
going on on the border during the
olympics i mean it's
prime evidence yeah anyways
exactly i think it's pretty clear you
know who's supporting this i mean
beijing has been very supportive of
putin even if this isn't going so well
but
up to the point that it's happening i
think there's it's pretty clear there so
what's next for china though yeah and
and for china i mean i think you know
you're talking about a place that has a
series of territorial goals and the one
that gets catches most attention is
obviously taiwan but then you have east
china see the south china sea the
himalayas where you had the use of the
chinese military against the indian
military in 2020 during the pandemic um
and i think um the way that i look at
this as a historian of of um you know
chinese sort of foreign policy strategy
and also military decision making is you
know they were prolific users of force
in the 20th century they fought you know
border conflicts or more among a variety
of their neighbors and they've made
absolutely clear in the 21st century
that they intend to use their military i
mean xi jinping speaks on a regular
basis about preparing to fight and win
wars you know we need that we're closer
than at any point to the great
rejuvenation of the chinese nation we
need the people's military to be you
know up to that task that sort of thing
is just regular regular regular um and
and those who you know we would be
foolish to ignore it so the point is i
think they are um they do intend to do
these things the question of when
is um
you know i think could be influenced
positively or negatively by events in
ukraine i mean the fact of this
resistance the fact of you know um you
know substantial russian casualties and
destruction of equipment and all of that
the fact of western sanctions that have
been crippling the potential for the use
of all of that against china should they
move on taiwan i think on one hand
they're seeing what the effects look
like and there's a you know a
possibility of um you know the united
states and our allies i think creating
deterrence by showing how costly this is
i mean if we're able to create
deterrence by showing you know what it
really means to go and attack a
neighboring state um we could create
hesitation in their minds and that's
what you need to do however
there's also the possibility that when
you look at the level of i think um you
know almost
philosophical alignment between putin
and xi jinping
i think there's a possibility that uh
depending on where these events go they
could also decide that you know now is
as good a time as any so we shouldn't be
surprised by what unfolds i think our
military leaders in the united states
have made it very clear that they see
china's preparing for action against
taiwan by 2027 or even sooner um
so you know in this decade i mean we
really should be watching this very
closely and hopefully the present events
can push in the opposite direction
towards deterrence so you you act uh
you you have a capacity as an advisor to
the us government
i i've been an advisor to the defense
department yeah and my book's been
widely read in government so um but
if it was to happen tomorrow versus 2027
i mean are we are we as a nation
especially given this wake-up call
of ukraine um
do you think that our military is going
to become galvanized and focused on
being prepared
because this has taken place and because
it's it's
it's i think it's it's taken on so much
more
as you say compared to to what happened
in hong kong and the world is watching
whereas there wasn't enough of the world
watching what happened in hong kong
well i think the issue here is that
really winning the contest with china um
you do not want this to be left to the
united states military because we failed
as a country to solve the strategic
issue and and that's something that i
can't emphasize enough i mean this
should not become the pentagon's problem
i mean what this really is is um we are
deeply engaged with china economically
we are funding china we are financing
its strategic industries and you can
look at any number of index funds and
the money that's pouring into their ship
building industrial base into their
policy banks into their energy sector
into their you name it into companies
still you know working on their human
rights atrocities i mean that is coming
directly from
the united states and the democracies um
into china's coffers and they're
repurposing this military excuse me
their economic ascendancy into military
power so that's the fundamental problem
that we have to solve is the problem i
think of
ultimately engagement in china by
multinationals engagement in china by
wall street and you know by london and
others and just the pouring of western
economic support into the people's
republic of china for the sake of
business is ultimately creating a
strategic
problem that we won't be able to solve
so so we have to begin i think by
scaling back our economic engagement
with china rebuilding our own strategic
industries rebuilding our industrial
base rebuilding our supply chains
preparing our military for the conflict
of the 21st century should they arrive
or to maintain the best possible
deterrence that we can
and hopefully prevent them but you can't
do that without winning an economic
contest and right now we're not even
fighting that fight
well i was going to say
there is is there even an entity uh
that could come together on the world
stage
and join the united states
because it seems like right now
and you're the expert but it seems like
china has done a bang-up job of
forging individual alliances with
countries on an economic level that make
them beholden to
china to where it's more difficult to
come together
a grouping a handful of countries even
though i have to say i was shocked at
australia and
it being in the lead of 139 some odd
countries that were demanding of the
world health health organization that
that that there be an investigation into
the viruses
origins
despite the blowback that they knew it
was going to cost their economy which it
since has
yes and and that's one of the important
things here is at the end of the day um
you know to sort of
change what ben franklin said i mean a
country that that wishes to have
prosperity at the expense of its freedom
will wind up with neither and i think
that's the deal that we think we're
doing we think that we can get rich with
china and that will be fine the answer
is you won't um you know we are really
putting ourselves in harm's way by um
you know allowing the place to to grow
to the size that it still could i mean
we do not want to let them become the
world's dominant economy the world's
largest economy that should be number
one for the united states of america
to make sure that we remain the world's
largest economy and that the alliance
system and the democracies remain the
um the most important economic community
jonathan we're going in the opposite
direction well we are but that's because
of the actions we're taking to
essentially finance the rise of china
and to you know build in its its
strategic industries and enterprises
we're gonna have to find alternatives i
mean that's really the fundamental
problem what would your advice be to our
nation's leaders well i think you have
to start um restricting investment into
china i mean there are a lot of ways to
do that you do that along the lines of
civil military fusion you know the use
of
private industry for the military
industrial enterprise um you do that
along the lines of um you know human
rights abuses and atrocities i mean that
takes out a whole number of companies
that can be invested and then you do it
along the lines of strategic industries
anything that actually you know creates
the
underpinnings for
not only um military and industrial
power but for growth itself because
that's a strategic good i mean if china
continues to grow
and to surpass us i mean this is a
difficult problem today imagine that in
the future um if if we are no longer um
the have the upper hand economically so
you know you can do all of that through
it sounds like you're describing
pseudo-sanctions
of a sort kind of interim type of
measures to mitigate china's growth what
i call it is economic containment it's
sort of an old cold war concept that was
used in part and and many interesting
strategies were devised so we actually
have a very
robust i think
experience with with doing economic uh
containment economic warfare economic
measures as instruments of national
strategy and policy it's just that we
haven't done it in a long time when it
comes to a serious existential contest
and that's the one with china i mean
we're seeing certain things unveiled on
russia but we're not yet taking the
initiative when it comes to the growth
of the people's republic of china um and
one has to just understand what the
consequences of that are when you do not
want to create a turning point in
history in which china is the dominant
power and we are not and that's what
we're financing and funding and building
right now
well i think we're
there are very few people who come out
and say it like that
that we're
financing the growth of
china that we're financing
the the potential and propensity for
china to become a larger economy that
we're facilitating it
so jonathan what's interesting
and you described kind of
where we were years ago we think of
world war ii we think of the allied
leaders coming together
um on behalf of it of a world that's in
desperate need of them
china has done kind of a bang-up job of
of forging alliances especially with its
belt and road initiative with individual
countries and and creating these
economic ties
that make individual countries beholden
to china and therefore potentially at
risk of not wanting to
pull that back
and and forge new alliances as you've
described in fact one of the things that
struck me in in our discussion right now
is that china came out unprovoked and
said that there will be no nato
in
in asia
and i don't recall anybody mentioning
forming nato in asia but it speaks to
the
it speaks to the document that was
released when when putin was
in moscow but
how do we come together on the world
stage
and
align with one another for the greater
good as you described well i think we're
going to have to go and do the hard work
of um in a way repairing the world
economy so that it's not dependent on
china i mean that's been in many ways
the basis of their grand strategy it has
the ideological elements it's got you
know a substantial military at this
point but the whole idea is to achieve
an economic ascendancy that's
unstoppable that you know the west can't
counteract and it puts them in you know
the position of dominance in the world
system overall um so you know you have
to go and
begin the process of realigning other
countries to
a free world economic sphere so on one
hand i think
reducing china's access to the alliance
system into europe to the united states
to allied asia you know japan and
australia finding ways to get off of
those dependencies which can be done in
many cases you know you just look at the
elements of it there are many ways to
achieve that and then you go into the
deeper battle for the emerging world and
you have to restructure the world
economy this is going to take time it'll
take a couple of decades at least but
you know you you have to begin to um
push china's economic influence back and
you know be competitive in places that
matter i mean we don't have enough um
you know
sort of uh effect in in the in the
emerging world i mean you don't you know
us multinationals are are doing what
they're doing but they don't necessarily
have the support of the united states
government or allied governments um to
to do more in latin america or asia or
africa i mean you need to start having
public private partnerships so we take
private capital private corporations uh
and the strategic vision coming from not
only the united states but from other
democracies and using that to build our
economic ties present better deals than
china can and ultimately to you know
basically push back their economic
influence across the globe and that's
going to be australia you know process
that will take um years but needs to
begin um and in the meantime
you know
they are obviously going to run into
their own problems um especially in the
2030s with demographics debt and that
could all come sooner so there's the
potential for an economic containment
strategy to harmonize with the
fundamental problems
of you know that china's going to go
through on its own and to to create sort
of a global retreat you know they're at
a 30-year low
in terms of their gdp growth i mean it
is what it is
right so it's and and yet still growing
and people are still investing and still
looking to expand their businesses and
that's right you know problematic
so
what what price do you see
the united states paying right now
it looks like it looks like we could
have double digit inflation
before it's all said and done you know i
i don't
i can speak for myself only but i doubt
i'm alone in not knowing
that russia and ukraine combined
accounted for a third of the world's
grains
i had no idea that it was that
concentrated
but what price do you think will pay
economically
and do you think there is a pathway
forward that doesn't lead to a hot war
two completely separate questions sure
well i mean to me this is the way you
avoid a hardware i mean you have a
communist party of china that's made
perfectly clear that it intends to use
force it's building up a military that's
designed to to do all of that so so
they're on that track already i mean
that's something that to prevent that i
think we have to have a broader grand
strategy that deals with the
fundamentals here of their rise and
ascendancy and you do not want to be um
you know to have the place in a position
of ascendancy that's then going to use
its military in either territorial you
know sense or for you know imperial
ambitions and they've talked explicitly
about preparing their military to
safeguard the security of our expanding
overseas interests it's just old school
19th century stuff really um
so so you have to deal with that
fundamental problem and i think that
that's how you hopefully avoid the
broader hot war is you start to rebuild
the world economy in such a way where
they are not um you know we it depends
less and less on them where we gain the
predominant position as we used to have
and then we're able to reinvest that
into deterrence
if we have military superiority and
economic superiority both as america
alone versus china but also as an
alliance system then you start to make
that calculation very different on their
end rather than an ascending power that
has a series of territorial goals and
sort of uh revenge's ambitions you have
a place that's begun to become boxed in
and that's what containment really is
about um but here you have to start in
this with the soviet union they were
already economically contained in a
sense because of their economic system
sometimes that's not the case so we have
to do that job for them and then the
military side of containment is very
much about just maintaining deterrence
in such a way where on no day is the
choice for war a smart choice
so it it it works to our benefit in a
way that china owns north of a trillion
dollars of u.s treasuries
uh because
russia has methodically
reduced any and all exposure to u.s
treasuries over the years and they've
built up their gold source even though
we managed to to to cut that off when
when push came to shut here in in
ukraine
but but it's undeniable that china's got
two trillion dollars combined of
u.s and european reserves so in that
sense
can one can one deduce that that china's
not as economically nimble
uh
as they would be otherwise because it's
not just our economy that's intertwined
with theirs but their economy that's
intertwined with ours i mean i don't
really buy the idea that interdependency
prevents war for the simple reason that
it never has um the first world war was
the first good example of a globalized
economy the second world war you know
germany and france trading partners
today ukraine russia trading partners
it's that's not it's never been
a preventative factor um in in modern
history i've learned something right and
in the 1930s you know it was some you
know american businessmen in munich
talking about how trade brings peace and
receiving prizes from hitler so you know
so that's always been i think the the
um sort of the economist's delusion so
to speak i mean where you believe that
that prevents things it doesn't what
really matters is is relative power i
think economically and to maintain you
know what churchill calls preponderance
um in world affairs where you you are
able to bring superior military and
economic effect to any situation that's
how america really maintained the peace
throughout the pax americana so that
sort of thing i think is the right goal
but you have to do that now in the
context of a globalized interconnected
world in which adversary states in very
dangerous
places have
absolutely spread across the global
economy and have that um you know that
that effect of not only being able to
coerce other nations as we've seen from
from australia to europe or or but also
um being able to drive benefits from the
globalized economy and you know for the
chinese communist party they do see it
already however as a double-edged sword
um you know they talk a lot about what
they call economic globalization and how
they need that because obviously they
need to solve their products and receive
investment and do all of that but at the
same time they're very fearful of the
dependencies that they've created right
so they're trying to create an atari of
their own you know both russia and china
and i think this is one of the very
important lessons of the current
situation um you know russia was was
trying to build a kind of what chatham
house called fortress economics you know
to shore up its you know reserves
prepare for all of that trying to
sanction proof itself right which they
did they were not successful with that
and you know for for china you have the
what xi jinping's you know his dual
circulation strategy of tying western
supply chains to china while excising
dependencies on the outside world you
know are they really going to be able to
do that it's much more complicated right
but the idea i mean the declaration
immediately followed china is going to
be food independent
it's right and what does that really
mean sounds great that doesn't come from
within their borders
so right
um
what uh
what has been most
what's put a smile on your face since
february the 24th
who on the world stage has has
surpassed your expectations has
has
has made ukraine bring out in your mind
at least
the good in people
well the ukrainians themselves i mean
zilinski i think has has made the entire
world um you know
respond to to this amazing thing that
we're seeing i think it's it's just an
extraordinary moment and um you know if
it makes sense i i heard a little bit oh
this is famous on linkedin i know
the wisdom of winston churchill well yes
this is the little thing that i i wrote
about it you know about a week and a
half ago but a word on the ukrainian
resistance
which has been by all accounts a
marvelous thing
i think of the words of winston
churchill who said of another country
resisting the russian army many decades
ago
finland superb nay sublime in the jaws
of peril finland shows what free men can
do
the service rendered by finland to
mankind is magnificent
here in our time of war and peace it is
ukraine that sacrifices for all of us
for all of us the world over who can
perceive and know the difference between
the forces of authoritarian malice
and those of democracy rights and
freedom as a whole
ukraine is not alone
in hong kong in xinjiang in other
theaters and trampled places in what is
already a global confrontation against
breakers of human beings in both moscow
and beijing
we can see what kinds of forces are
rising in our time
and so the ukrainians fight not only for
their own homes
but also for the cause of freedom and
sovereignty that matters to us all
we will soon see the price of that fight
as it unfolds
this is a moment and a resistance that
portends other things to come
ukraine fights for all of us
as has been said in history
ich bin nein berliner
russian warship goethe
and ukraine's superb nay sublime in the
jaws of peril ukraine shows what free
men can do
the service rendered by ukraine to
mankind is magnificent
well those are
truly inspiring words we will put them
up on the screen
and
before
before cutting off this conversation
i'd like to point to something that is
critical for anybody watching
and that is uh the perils of symbolism
so we know that that during nazi germany
the swastika itself was was it was a
symbol of hatred
the worldwide and it has remained that
way today and
as we come to you on west 40th street in
from a studio
we had no idea that there was a symbol
right behind us so maybe you can explain
what this is and clarify for everybody
watching that this was simply a
coincidence and certainly not placed
with any reason
because i don't think that there's an
appreciation for what the ukrainians are
seeing when they see the letter z
well sadly as we have recorded this
segment we've noticed that there's a
the same symbol that appears on russian
tanks um that are invading ukraine which
is certainly not our intentions
you know so so an unfortunate
um
choice of background and
but it gives us prism it gives us a
prism at the same time into
into being able to look out the eyes of
ukrainian and
and see something that that strikes fear
in their heart and also given your
wonderful words
incites bravery
well in any case i mean we are um
in quite an important historical moment
and i think it's
it's certainly um this crisis is one
that
that is uh
shaking the world no doubt and more so
than almost anything we've ever seen um
you know in my lifetime
um
and
you know most importantly it's it's uh i
think
about something even larger you know i
mean we're at the beginning of hopefully
shedding our illusions about
you know two powers that are going to be
incredibly dangerous to the rest of us
in the world
and our
path towards
handling these giant issues
has hopefully already become
well
i thank you i thank you for your life's
work and your study
and helping illuminate
through history
and more importantly not just to talk
about what's happened and what is
happening
but
to explain to everybody what we can do
to forge a path forward
to make sure that we stop the atrocities
that we're seeing in their tracks
thank you for spending so much time
again at this last minute i really
appreciate it and i will i will help to
spread the word so that your work
and your book continue to open the
world's eyes to the importance of the
moment that we're in thank you danielle
great to meet you
well that was extraordinary um dr
jonathan ward
again we are living in in the moment we
are
witnessing
atrocities that our generation has never
seen
and we're also witnessing bravery and
courage on the part of
the ukrainian people and i hope that
having a little bit more history now
as to where they're coming from and more
importantly understanding the gravity of
what it is that our democratic leaders
choose to do going forward
in order to seize the moment but for the
better
for the better pathway forward going
forward such that despots do not have
greater control over our future but
indeed less
if you have any interest in learning on
the more on the economic side of china
then have a look at my most recent
episode
with leland miller of the china beige
book until next time this is danielle
dimartino booth with down the middle
thank you
[Music]
you